[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
Parlement Hebdo les temps forts de
l'actualité à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat sous le regard de notre invité
et on accueille cette semaine Loïc Hervé
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur de la
Haute-Savoie et membre du groupe
centriste au Sénat et beaucoup
d'actualités pour vous Loïc Hervé
l'hommage les questions après la
démission du maire de Saint-Brévin les
pins en Loire-Atlantique l'élu était la
cible de menaces sa maison et sa voiture
ont été incendiées ils soutenaient un
projet de transfert d'un centre de
migrants dans sa commune
c'est acté une commission d'enquête
parlementaire pour faire la lumière sur
le fond Marianne créé en 2011 par
Marianne Chappat pour lutter contre le
séparatisme au cœur de la faire des
soupçons de détournement d'argent public
et puis le drapeau européen divise à
l'Assemblée nationale objet de la
discorde une proposition de loi qui
oblige les communes de plus de 1500
habitants à afficher le drapeau sur les
mairies Yannick Morez le maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins en
Loire-Atlantique a donc démissionné sous
la pression et la violence de l'extrême
droite cette semaine députée sénateurs
ont exprimé leur indignation regardez ce
soir mais chers collègues nous apprenons
la démission de Yannick Morez le maire
de Saint-Brévin victime lui de ce qu'il
qualifie être un terrorisme d'extrême
droite puisque son domicile a été
incendié parce qu'il défendait
l'installation d'un centre d'accueil et
de demandeurs d'asile et donc des
événements de cette nature
nous interpelle
je suis
profondément
inquiète et profondément préoccupé que
dans notre pays des gens puissent d'une
manière aussi lâche et aussi violence
sans prendre à une personne qui a une
autorité qui exerce une autorité qui a
été élue par ses concitoyens et qui fait
juste
son job de son job de mer Loïc Hervé
vous êtes aussi président délégué de
l'Association des petites villes de
France comment vous réagissez à la
démission de ce maire sous à la pression
sur la violence de l'extrême droite ce
qui se passe est extrêmement grave
évidemment les faits qui se sont
produits maintenant quelques mois de
l'incendie du domicile de sommaire mais
surtout sa démission ce cri d'alarme
d'ailleurs nous allons le recevoir au
Sénat dans quelques jours c'est
la manifestation d'un maire qui n'en
peut plus
qui a eu peur pour lui-même pour sa
famille j'ai moi-même vécu cette
situation de de
menaces de mort j'ai été protégé pendant
près d'un mois par la par la par la
gendarmerie c'est extrêmement dur à
vivre pour vous-même pour votre famille
donc
l'émotion est forte par rapport au fait
qu'ils se produit par rapport à sa
démission
j'entendais que on pourrait
éventuellement renforcer encore le droit
pénal je pense que on touche on a fait
de sauter dans ce pays un tabou
qui est le fait que finalement sans
prendre à des élus c'est pas si choquant
que ça alors les émotions de l'émotion
légitime notamment à gauche et je la
comprends et je la partage mais je pense
qu'il faut on devrait être beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus solidaire et beaucoup plus
aux côtés de ce maire qui démissionne et
pour marquer dans la société française
qui n'est pas possible de s'en prendre à
un maire et qu'on il doit pouvoir
continuer sa missionait la sécurité de
Yannick Morez que pour vous il n'a pas
été assez protégé
par l'État vous savez quand je ne sais
pas je peux pas parler de je n'en sais
rien il nous le dira sans doute quand il
sera entendu par la commission des lois
et la mission quand moi j'ai été
concerné j'ai été protégé et à la fois à
l'époque Bernard Cazeneuve et le préfet
de département qui qui s'appelait George
François Leclerc tous les deux
m'ont protégé ont mis les mesures
nécessaires vis-à-vis de moi mais je
pense que ce soit pas de sujet le sujet
aussi ce sont ces groupuscules pour
Monsieur le Maire en question à
Saint-Brevin c'est des militants et des
groupuscules d'extrême droite qui
clairement s'en sont pris à lui pour moi
c'était plutôt la mouvance c'est la fist
pour d'autres ce seront des mouvements
d'extrême gauche donc dans ce pays pour
contrer la puissance de ces de ces
groupes musculaires on a l'impression
que les lois ne suffisent pas il y a
évidemment le droit pénal une fois qu'on
a confondu les auteurs
et puis il y a la prévention c'est à
dire que dans cette commune de
Saint-Brévin on a laissé régulièrement
se faire des manifestations contre le
maire donc l'axe de personnes qui n'ont
rien à voir avec la commune de
Saint-Brévin ah non mais c'est à dire
que c'est est-ce que c'est
manifestations qui ont qui avaient lieu
régulièrement dans cette commune et dont
le maire avait demandé qu'elle soit
interdite
elles ne l'ont pas été il faudra
d'ailleurs qu'on le regarde de manière
de manière objective quand la commission
des lois va entendre sa mère et qu'on
demande des comptes au préfet du
département aux différents ministres
concernés sur la le fait qu'on laisse
dans une commune qui il s'agit du
transfert d'un centre d'accueil de
demandeurs d'asile dans ma commune il y
en avait il y en avait un précisément et
c'est pour cristallisé qui a généré un
tel donc c'est compliqué la gestion pour
les îles locaux la gestion des cadas
c'est très compliqué
l'association des élus locaux à ces
structures là elle est très relative
donc il aussi des éléments
très concrets dans l'administration de
ces sujets là sur le terrier de les
territoires qu'il faut revoir rapidement
pour conclure sur ce sujet Loïc Hervé ce
qu'il faut des mesures supplémentaires
pour protéger nos élus alors on l'a voté
au Sénat à plusieurs reprises y compris
dans la dans la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur dont j'étais le
rapporteur avec Marc-Philippe de Bresse
dans cette dans cette maison ici au
Sénat évidemment il y a des mesures de
droit pénal à prendre mais je le redis
je pense qu'il y a des mesures de
prévention et que on peut pas quand une
situation se est délétère et et ce
cristallise sur une personne ou dans une
commune faut pas attendre que le
domicile lumière soit incendié et il
faut pas attendre que le maire
démissionne
je trouve que la démission du maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins crée une situation
dans laquelle il y a un émoi politique
et qui est tout à fait légitime et du
soutien à son égard c'est logique mais
je pense qu'on allait trop laisser
traîner les choses et on a laissé
dégénérer la situation on va parler du
fond Marianne Loic Hervé puisque le
Sénat a voté cette semaine en faveur de
la création d'une commission d'enquête
sur ce fond avec l'objectif pour les
sénateurs et bien faire la lumière sur
la gestion de ce fond un public créé en
2021 par Marlène Schiappa pour lutter
contre la radicalisation en ligne à les
sénateurs dans leur commission d'enquête
devront faire attention à ne pas
empiéter sur l'enquête judiciaire qui
est également ouverte Flora sauvage
validez à l'unanimité par la commission
des Lois du Sénat la création de la
commission d'enquête sur le fond
Marianne va chercher à comprendre
comment ont été attribués les
subventions aux diverses associations
qui en ont bénéficié Claude Raynal le
président de la commission des finances
à l'initiative de cette commission
d'enquête transparties zanes à une
multitude de questions comment s'est
créé le fond Marianne qui en a eu l'idée
comment il a été monté comment le choix
des associations et selon quels critères
les associations ont-elles été retenu le
fond Marianne a été créé en 2021 par la
ministre Marlène Schiappa après
l'assassinat du professeur Samuel Paty
doté de 2,5 millions d'euros à louer à
17 associations pour lutter contre les
phénomènes de radicalisation et
promouvoir les valeurs de la République
une enquête journalistique avait pointé
du doigt la gestion opaque de ce fonds
publics on est le pays au monde en tout
cas dans le monde développé où on a le
plus d'impôts on a le plus de
prélèvement et on a le plus de dépenses
publiques une exigence de contrôle pour
savoir comment c'est font qui sont des
fonds publics ont été utilisés le PNF le
parquet national financier a ouvert une
information judiciaire pour des soupçons
de détournement de fonds publics abusent
confiance et prise illégale d'intérêt
une procédure en parallèle de la
création de la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale nous ne savions pas s'il PNF
aller de lui-même aussi engagé une
démarche donc
permettez-moi l'expression chez trivial
nous avons eu le pif mais les sénateurs
devront prendre garde à ne pas marcher
sur les plates bandes du parquet
national financier la commission
d'enquête débutera ses travaux mardi
prochain avec l'audition de Christian
Gravel le secrétaire général du comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance et de la radicalisation le
Sénat s'est donné trois mois pour rendre
ses conclusions sur le fond Marianne
a eu raison de lancer cette commission
d'enquête sur cette affaire du fond
Marianne bien sûr chaque fois qu'un
centime d'argent public ne va pas à
l'endroit pour lequel le Parlement a
décidé qu'il aille chaque fois qu'il y a
un risque ou un soupçon de détournement
de fonds publics sur des questions aussi
graves on vient de parler à l'instant
d'un maire qui a été victime de
violences etc donc c'est tous ces sujets
sont évidemment connexes là il s'agit
d'argent public la presse a fait son
travail
la justice est en train de faire le sien
le Parlement qui contrôle l'action du
Gouvernement c'est-à-dire qu'il contrôle
l'action des ministres au nom du peuple
c'est-à-dire que les députés les
sénateurs quand ils créent une
commission d'enquête et qu'ils m'ont
demandé des comptes à un délégué
interministériel à des ministres à telle
ou telle fonctionnaire de l'emploi de
ces fonds publics
à ce moment là les députés les sénateurs
sont absolument dans leur rôle
constitutionnel on a oublié cette
fonction de contrôle parental et une
commission d'enquête parlementaire c'est
ça en fait elle a beaucoup de pouvoir
cette commission d'enquête parlementaire
néanmoins elle ne peut pas on l'a dit
dans le sujet qui vient de passer elle
ne peut pas interférer empiéter sur
l'enquête judiciaire est-ce que c'est
possible à faire est-ce que ça ne risque
pas tout de même d'interférer par moment
alors on a déjà eu des cas je pense
notamment à l'affaire Benalla qui a été
la plus la plus médiatisée ou et de la
même manière une enquête judiciaire ou
était était diligenté donc il faut être
très vigilant pour que les magistratif
sur leur travail avec les parlementaires
ça n'empêche pas que de manière générale
sur la création de ce fond les décisions
prises que Claude Raynal et Bruno
retaillons ont évoqué c'est-à-dire la
manière dont l'argent a été orienté vers
des associations les fonds publics de
quelle manière de quelle manière
c'est public aujourd'hui et aussi le
contrôle à posteriori parce que quand
vous faites un choix d'une association à
qui vous allez donner de l'argent vous
devez faire un contrôle de l'exécution
et de l'emploi de cet argent après coup
c'est ça est-ce que tout ça a été fait
dans les dans les règles de l'art et
est-ce que donc je pense que la
commission des finances pourra faire son
travail je connais bien les
parlementaires qui seront en charge de
cette enquête je suis sûr qu'ils seront
très vigilants à bien respecter les
compétences de la justice en tout cas
Marlène chapelle concernée par cette
affaire puisque en tant que ministre de
la Citoyenneté à l'époque en 2021 elle
avait lancé ce fond piloter ce fond
Marianne aujourd'hui elle est mise en
charge et bien du secteur associatif
est-ce qu'elle peut rester en poste
ça c'est pas moi dans des idées vous
savez que c'est au présent de la
République de décider de qui est composé
le gouvernement du pays il se trouve que
Marianne chappa a un peu disparu des
radars y compris pour des raisons
personnelles qui ont fait qu'une partie
importante de son poste de son
portefeuille ministériel lui était
retiré
je pense que dans un ministre dans un
gouvernement où il y a 45 ministres
quand il y a des difficultés de cet
ordre là et des soupçons qui sont
importants il me semble que le Président
de la République et la première ministre
devrait en tirer toutes les conséquences
ça n'appartient pas au Parlement dans
dessiner mais à ceux qui ont nommé
madame Schiappa assez différents postes
alors on va parler d'un autre sujet
faut-il rendre obligatoire le
pavoisement du drapeau européen sur le
fronton des mairies des députés en tout
cas ont voté cette proposition de loi
présentée par le groupe Renaissance mais
mais seuls les communes de plus de 1500
habitants seront concernés le vote a eu
lieu à l'issue d'une longue séance
mouvementée que nous résume Stéphane et
Pierre
c'est le drapeau de la discorde la
bannière européenne le gros Renaissance
voleront obligatoire sur les mairies aux
côtés du drapeau français aujourd'hui
c'est l'usage mais ce n'est pas une
obligation cette idée défendue par le
député Renaissance Mathieu Lefebvre a
provoqué des débattons dû à l'Assemblée
pour les insoumis c'est une proposition
absolument
inutile
c'est un sujet de diversion et quand les
Français apprennent que on est en train
de parler du drapeau européen plutôt que
de parler de la question du pouvoir
d'achat des salaires de l'inflation de
la retraite à 60 ans et non pas à 64 ou
bien encore de la Sixième République
bien les Français se disent mais que
font nos députés le rassemblement
national lui s'est livré à une attaque
en règle basée sur le nom à la
Constitution européenne en 2005 malgré
le vote des Français vous avez imposé
dans nos rues dans nos mairies sur mon
ministère dans cette hémicycle derrière
le président de la République ce drapeau
contre la volonté du peuple c'est que
vous méprisez le peuple français Mathieu
Lefèvre assume le caractère symbolique
de sa position dans l'hémicycle de la
même élargi le débat pour ou contre la
construction européenne renvoyant
dosados les oppositions en réalité ceux
qui parmi nous ont du mal à masquer leur
malaise face au drapeau étoilé en toute
autant de mal à masquer leur rêve de
frexit déguisés rouge pour les uns et
bruns pour les autres le député a réussi
à faire adopter sa proposition de loi
130 voix pour 109 contre le Parti
socialiste la voté pas les républicains
qui rognit sur une obligation très
édulcorée elle ne concernera que les
communes de plus de 1500 habitants pour
ne pas alourdir le budget des villages
où le symbole existe ou il n'existe pas
on a failli avoir un symbole à 3500
habitants on l'a finalement à 1500 mais
c'est quoi ces symboles qui sont
négociables et pourquoi pas 1000
pourquoi pas 4000 pourquoi pas 10000 ça
n'a pas de sens
alors que les députés ont débattu durant
plus de 5 heures de cette proposition
finalement 78% des communes ne seront
pas concernés par cette obligation
Loïc Hervé va bien cette question
60 plus de 70% des communes voire plus
ne seront pas concernés par par cette
obligation est-ce que pour vous ce qui a
été voté à du sens
je suis européen j'aime son drapeau et
son hymne
j'ai été militant militante toujours de
l'Europe fédérale du Mouvement européen
etc je trouve irresponsable dans la
situation politique du pays de lancer un
tel débat le drapeau européen qui est un
très beau drapeau il est très présent
dans la vie quotidienne des Français
l'extrême droite le dénonce me surprend
pas mais il y a beaucoup de mairies en
France qui ont un drapeau européen sur
leur façade quelle que soit leur taille
et était-il nécessaire dans dans le dans
la tension actuelle du pays de lancer un
tel débat
à l'Assemblée nationale je pense que
cette irresponsable et ça fait en plus
porter un débat sur
cette relation d'un peuple le peuple
français à la construction européenne à
l'histoire européenne le 9 mai 2023 on
avait besoin plutôt de concorde d'amitié
européenne éenne de symboles positif
plutôt qu'un débat de ce type là qui en
plus va créer des obligations aux maires
nous ici au contraire au principe de la
libre administration des communes
les mères en ont ras-le-bol qu'on leur
impose des normes supplémentaires à
fortiori dans le domaine symbolique
alors qu'ils sont aujourd'hui plutôt
préoccupés par d'autres réalités liées
aux finances locales liés à la mise en
place de tout un tas de lois
qui sont encore difficiles les
conséquences de la loi nôtre les
questions de de d'assainissement qui
sont des choses très concrètes et qui
sont leur quotidien vous pouvez laisser
le drapeau européen
au sommet de Saint mature ce serait ce
serait responsable là c'est
irresponsable alors on sait ce débats et
moi je trouve que alors que l'Europe
traverse une situation qui est
compliquée il faut qu'on si on veut
sauver l'Union européenne si on veut
sauver la construction européenne il
faut revenir à si fondamentaux
fondamentaux de ses pères fondateurs
Robert Schuman et Jean Monnet et avoir
quelque chose de positif et pas ce type
de débat complètement décalé
par rapport à la réalité des élus et des
Français
en militant européen alors que j'ai
toujours eu quand j'étais mère pendant
10 ans le drapeau européen il est
toujours évidemment devant la sur le la
façade de la mairie de marnin
Haute-Savoie et c'est heureux je ne
voterai pas ce type d'obligation parce
que ça n'est pas ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas sain alors on va parler d'un autre
sujet que vous connaissez bien le projet
de loi immigration puisque après avoir
rapporté à l'automne le gouvernement on
veut finalement présenter son texte au
mois de juillet et il lance une série de
consultations des parlementaires de leur
côté les LR vont déposer deux
propositions de loi écoutez erikiotti et
Bruno retaillod nous prenons nos
responsabilités le gouvernement la sans
doute vu c'est pour cela qu'il
use d'une forme de de revirement
multiples on n'y comprend plus rien les
jours pairs et un texte les jours un
père il y en a un autre c'est un
gouvernement alternatif les bonnes
propositions elles seront dans contexte
des républicains dans les deux textes
alors celui de nature constitutionnelle
et celui qui relève d'une loi simple
vous retrouverez un certain nombre de
points qu'on a déjà voté par exemple la
transformation de l'aide médicale d'État
parce que c'est la gabegie en aide
médicale d'urgence pour restreindre le
palier de soins bien d'autres
dispositions aussi puis il y aura un
texte de loi constitutionnelle on
touchera en tout cas à la possibilité
d'article 11 d'avoir dans le champ du
référendum législatif évidemment la
question migratoire ça me paraît être
important
est-ce que vous pourriez voter ces
propositions de loi des républicains qui
veulent donc durcir la politique
migratoire notamment en diminuant l'aide
médicale d'État alors d'abord avant de
les voter j'aimerais les connaître et
deuxièmement j'aimerais vous dire que si
le groupe des Républicains l'Assemblée
nationale ou au Sénat les groupes vont
faire des propositions le groupe de
l'Union centriste va faire également et
peut-être que nous avons une approche
sur les questions migratoires qui est un
peu plus mesuré
et notamment face à la situation
démographique et la situation de
l'emploi dans le pays
j'ai entendu Bruno Retailleau dire que
l'immigration n'était plus une chance
pour la France donc on est déjà on
comprend déjà la tonalité que les
républicains veulent donner à ce débat
nous groupes de l'Union centriste s'il y
a des propositions qui sont bonnes chez
nos collègues des républicains
évidemment nous les voterons mais nous
aurons nos propositions nos propres
propositions
Philippe bonne Carrère sénateur
centriste Muriel jour sont les
rapporteurs du texte qui a été retiré
par le gouvernement je pense que nous
aurons l'occasion dans les semaines qui
viennent de poser nos jalons et nos
sujets de débat avec nos collègues des
républicains mais aussi avec des
propositions qui seront des propositions
propres qui sont pas forcément celle de
qui seront totalement consensuelles
quelles proposition par exemple des
sénateurs centrist est-ce que ça veut
dire que pour le groupe centriste du
Sénat et bien l'immigration est une
chance pour la France vous savez c'est
le vieux débat et les écrits bernastasie
il y a une il y a une trentaine d'années
la question de la maîtrise de
l'immigration est une question centrale
nous avons aujourd'hui trop d'immigrés
irréguliers qui arrivent dans notre pays
qui arrive sur le territoire l'Union
européenne donc la régulation est une
soupe bonne chose en soi en revanche
nous savons une situation de l'emploi
qui est tendu il y a tout un tas de
secteurs d'activités je viens de
Haute-Savoie donc je peux en parler de
d'expérience des situations de tension
dans lesquelles l'immigration
peut-être une solution à un certain
nombre de nos métiers en tension c'était
toute la partie du soft du volet du du
projet de loi qui a été qui a été déposé
par le Gouvernement ce débat là il est
important les travailleurs sans papier
dans les secteurs une solution très
difficile à faire comprendre parce que
elle aurait envoyé un message qui était
pas forcément celui qu'on attendait en
tous les cas moi pour venir émettre
rendu le week-end dernier en Italie et
la semaine d'avant au Québec je peux
vous assurer que un certain nombre de
nos de nos voisins ou de pays dont nous
sommes proches ont une
approche de l'immigration qui est
beaucoup plus pragmatique que l'anneau
donc pas d'idéologie là-dessus la lutte
contre les filières la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine évidemment
mais soyons raisonnable sur la question
de notre réalité du marché de l'emploi
nous sommes en tension dans beaucoup de
métiers et il faut que nous ayons une
une capacité de répondre à ça est-ce que
vous soutenez l'idée comme certains le
propose un référendum sur l'immigration
est-ce que ce serait une bonne ou une
mauvaise idée pour vous avec la culture
plébiscitaire du référendum dans notre
pays non parce que
le référendum c'est répondre par oui et
par ordre non à une question complexe ça
va qu'on déposerait un projet de loi et
on dit aux Français voilà voilà le
projet de loi c'est oui ou non le
travail de d'écriture de la loi est un
travail qui est dans notre pays un
travail être entre les mains des
parlementaires du gouvernement qui les
propositions mais ensuite des
parlementaires députés sénateurs qui
viennent faire des modifications ce
qu'on appelle des amendements et qui
travaillent le texte donc un texte aussi
aussi complexe et qui va toucher tout un
tas de de domaines des questions de
police des questions de justice des
questions économiques doit être
travaillée par les parlementaires et on
ne doit pas s'en déposséder le Carver on
va finir à cette émission par un sujet
qui préoccupe beaucoup de jeunes le
passage du permis de conduire il est de
plus en plus difficile de passer son
permis de conduire cela coûte cher il y
a de forts délais d'attente alors dans
ce contexte et bien pour faciliter
l'obtention du permis le Sénat a voté
mercredi une proposition de loi venue de
l'Assemblée nationale qui crée une
plateforme numérique recensant des aides
financières de l'État et des
collectivités pour passer son permis le
compte personnel de formation permettra
de financer tous les permis de conduire
et puis l'autorisation actuelle des
agents publics et des contractuels à
faire passer le permis sera étendu au
niveau national pour raccourcir encore
les délais le carré vous étiez
rapporteur au Sénat de ce texte est-ce
que vous pensez que ça va vraiment
changer la situation actuelle alors les
mesures de la proposition de loi de
Sacha Oullier que le Sénat a modifié et
donc la provision de loi a été adoptée
cette semaine c'est
des mesures qui sont attendues et qui
sont bienvenus on aurait pu imaginer un
débat plus large sur la question de
l'âge 17 ans sur la question des visites
médicales notamment pour nos
compatriotes seniors et la question du
permis de conduire à vie
on aurait pu aussi avoir des bas
beaucoup plus profond sur la conduite
accompagnée sur le coup mais parce que à
l'échelle d'une proposition de loi
de nos collègues de notre collègue
député président de la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale c'est
difficile de porter le débat en ayant
pas tous les éléments notamment les
éléments d'études d'impact la relecture
par le Conseil d'État et puis pardon
mais l'agenda on a eu quelques jours
pour pour préparer ce texte donc moi
j'ai regardé avec mes collègues de la
commission des lois à ce texte avait
bienveillance on a fait quelques
propositions de modifications qui ont
été adoptées et donc ces mesures pour
rentrer en vigueur rapidement sur le
compte formation et la mobilisation du
conformation pour l'é largissement des
différents permis sur la lutte contre la
fraude donc quelques mesures qui sont
attendues et cette plateforme qui va
permettre à un jeune en rentrant son
code postal de dire bah j'ai droit à
toutes ces aides vous savez que c'est
près de 1600 euros
en moyenne pour passer le permis en un
autre pays pour les familles c'est très
cher et enfin un sujet où on a pu parler
jeunesse et parler aux jeunes et bien
merci mes agent tendus le kervé on va
terminer cette émission avec un regard
rapide sur l'ordre du jour à venir
[Musique]
et mardi au Sénat à la commission
d'enquête sur à l'affaire du fond
Marianne va lancer ses auditions les
sénateurs vont notamment s'intéresser au
rôle dans cette affaire du comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance et de la radicalisation
mardi toujours une autre commission
d'enquête du Sénat à celle sur la
pénurie de médicaments auditionnera les
anciens ministres de la Santé Xavier
Bertrand et Marisol Touraine et puis
mercredi les sénateurs auditionneront
donc le maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins victimes de
violences et qui a donc choisi de
démissionner
à l'Assemblée les députés que xamineront
le projet de loi pour renforcer la
prévention contre le risque incendie et
notamment les mégafeux ce sera lundi et
mardi à l'agenda le projet de loi qui
vise à accélérer la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires et bien il
sera soumis au vote final et c'est la
fin de ce numéro de Parlement hebdom
merci beaucoup merci kervé d'avoir été
notre invité cette semaine et merci à
tous d'avoir suivi cette émission à très
bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]